what's mcgregor syndrome
it's made up well what is it in the
confines really close to mcguffin
syndrome it's uh
it's a thing that makes 80 year olds
tired a lot
nina
what bad guy good guy team up have you
chosen to talk about today
so brian i know that when you talk about
good guy bad guy team ups in the mcu
most people would probably think about
thorin loki that's a that's a good go-to
example but i wanted to pick a different
mcu villain turned good
because while they're only bad briefly
it has really fun ramifications for the
rest of the mcu so my pick is
uh
wanda maximoff who is introduced as a
villain in age of ultron and ultimately
becomes an avenger and then got her own
show so i mean she's she's very very
briefly a villain right she's working
with ultron to destroy the avengers
wanda and her brother realized that uh
ultron is pretty hell-bent on created on
genociding everyone so
they get out of there they join the they
briefly both join the avengers until
pedro is is uh killed in battle
but obviously we get great ramifications
that which means we get elizabeth olsen
and the rest of the mcu uh appearing
alongside various avengers and then we
get one division which is probably my
favorite
it's definitely my favorite of the mcu
television shows i think it's one of the
uh most interesting things the mcu has
done in a really long time in terms of
how different and fascinating it is and
i
i loved it when i watched it i think i'm
already ready to watch it for a second
time even though it came out fairly
recently relatively um and so
yeah even though i mean and she's not
called scarlet witch at the beginning
obviously that's a title sharon slater
but you know wanda is introduced in a
post-credits scene remind me which
movie is the post credit scene is it is
it an iron man
thank you it was not an iron man
but you know she's very briefly
introduced as a very powerful villain
and the stuff that she does to the
avengers when she's fighting them is
horrifying yeah she's like relive your
worst memories yeah it's that's a scary
villain one's fast and one's weird yeah
exactly just like she's weird yeah
that's her power she's her power is
weird you know i think we're all
starting to realize she's probably one
of the more powerful avengers out there
in terms of sheer
magical trickery so yeah i i know she
wasn't a villain for very long but she
eventually teams up with the with the uh
good guys and she becomes a villain of
of sorts and one division of large
swords by trapping an entire town in a
grief you know driven fantasy world but
her grief prison yeah exactly but
yeah i think i think her journey's been
pretty dang fascinating and i love that
she does not stay a villain
and disappear
what's cool about this one too is that
it mirrors the com like you know all
these mcu movies they're all adaptations
of comic books but a long time ago i
think a lot of comic book fans generally
were started to become okay with the
fact that these movies were going to
take pretty extreme liberties they go
far from the source material enough but
keep the spirits so similarly
um scarlet witch and quicksilver started
out as bad guys they were members of the
brotherhood of evil mutants because they
were magneto's kids right right i forgot
that and so and then eventually they
become avengers
and they're you know testy and they they
fight with the team but that's what all
marvel comics characters did because
that's
interesting and eventually you know
they've become
you know heroes for decades but then um
maybe like
15
15-ish years ago there was this
storyline um called avengers
disassembled where all the avengers
started getting
attacked and some of them were even
killed and it turns out that this was a
manifestation of wanda's grief
over her her lost kids
and she wound up being the source of all
of these these problems without anybody
realizing it she was causing all these
these terrible things to happen against
the avengers and then that's eventually
what led to house of m where she said no
more mutants and they referenced that in
cute little very subtle ways and wanted
the wine bottle and everything yeah so
it's i think i'm really glad that you
brought that one up because i think that
is a really good it's a great bad guy
good guy team up and it's it's easy to
rem it's hard to remember i wanted to
say
that wanda starts out as a villain and
that's kind of what makes her
pretty villainous
turn in wanda vision even though she
didn't really know quite what she was
doing that much more believable so i
think that's a really good one yeah and
and yeah i just i love that like um you
know we've talked about the mcu maybe
having a villain problem before where
you you get a great villain but they
have to disappear because they have to
be vanquished so turning her into a good
guy ensures wanda's longevity and means
that she gets to be a huge part of the
mcu for the foreseeable future which i
love because i think
sh she has really grown on me as a
character and has become one of my
favorite avengers
yeah and and you know also that she can
probably turn bad exactly yeah there's a
lot of complexity to yeah she contains
multitudes we love we love that it
contains multitudes yeah
we love to see it so yeah that's my pick
wanda maximoff scarlet witch
that's a good pick
tom what was your pick for the best good
guy bad guy
team up in movie history
brian nina
i'm gonna paint a picture for you okay
all right
it's 1997.
nina you're about seven years old right
yeah it's very weird how quickly you
knew that yeah just turned
46
46 yep
and you're both
so excited because uh because one of the
largest
motion picture events in in movie
history is about to take place
i think we all know what i'm talking
about do we want to say it all at once
one two three
robin batman and robin robin batman i
don't think that's their titanic came
out anyway
starring
it was it was a titanic feat it was a it
was a terrific movie and uh george
clooney's batman you've got chris
o'donnell as robin yeah it's a beautiful
film that ends with one of my favorite
uh villain hero team ups of all time
batman and robin's butler alfred uh get
something called mcgregor syndrome and
the only person that knows how to cure
it is mr freeze
what's mcgregor syndrome
it's made up well what is it in the
confines
of mcguffin syndrome it's uh
it's a thing that makes 80 year olds
tired a lot
if you can believe it like it's a dark
world gotham but in this world so alfred
just gets sleepy and need to lie down
yeah
and everyone's like no you can't bring
his his billionaire client who he raised
as much dinner anymore
amazing too much gazpacho for one old
man to carry yeah and uh amazing
so
they they they punch mr freeze into
into curing this old man of his disease
they're like hey we've got this old guy
who makes form-fitting clothes for his
niece in the basement
and we cannot live without him as a
constant presence in our life incredible
and so mr freeze uh uh saves his life
they uh
they inject this old man with glow
sticks
doesn't he deliver a line too he says
take two of these and call me in the
morning right doesn't it yeah yeah
he says exactly that while he hands him
two glow sticks that will that will cure
the old man
uh
sounds like an snl sketch
this is not i know this is real like it
doesn't sound they appeal to his
humanity right because they're like
that's what your wife had and that's
what our butler has
that's exactly right
he's like all right batman you win this
time here's some medicine take me to
jail
the the best part about this this deal
uh to my eyes anyway is that uh
afterwards batman says we're gonna have
your frozen wife sent to the prison that
we're putting you in uh so that you can
keep doing science to her so there's
kind of there's kind of a quid pro quo
thing that happens uh the implication
does also seem to be that they get it
hooked up so that mr freeze gets to keep
his cool like killing people armor
uh while he's in jail and then uh be in
the same prison cell as poison ivy so
they essentially they said like we've
watched you kill
dozens of people uh but we're just we're
going to set it up so that you get to
share a prison cell with this person
that you want dead mm-hmm it's not a
realistic movie i yeah i don't think
that's happening
i don't see that i don't know not sure
everything else about the movie really
stands up to scrutiny i think but
how do you feel about uh
about batman's suit
a very popular one
nipple i have no problems with it
no no it's perfect
no no no it's exactly right
uh my my second choice would be uh also
batman but at the end of the snyder cut
when they do the uh the flash forward to
the future and he teams up with the
joker and there's just no reason for it
yeah besides i think my theory is that
zack snyder spent the last like three
years telling everybody batman's gonna
say the f word in this movie and then he
it was like three weeks before his
homework was due
and he was like oh i forgot to put in
the batman he was like he was like we're
shooting the scene tomorrow and i don't
i don't have anything
it's like 3am the night before
i need half a gallon of grease paint
and some rubber gloves
and jared leto's phone number
yeah
perfect
that was my other favorite all right
brian you've been uncharacteristically
quiet about this whole good guy bad guy
situation i've been quiet this whole
time
everybody misses me talking yeah yes i
miss you talking same well
so
we published an article on looper about
this very topic um and some of the the
choices on there are pretty good
um we've got batman and catwoman teaming
up in dark knight rises rocky and apollo
creed from rocky iii
terminator 2 when the terminator the
t800 right t800 comes back from the
first movie he's an unstoppable killing
machine in the first movie comes back in
the second movie and he says come with
me if you want to live the villain has
become the hero it's great it's one it
is really one of the best bad guy good
guy team ups
um
we've also got in this list here
um
where luke and darth vader team up at
the end of return of the jedi which
great choice yeah it's a good choice but
when i saw it i was also kind of like
do they team up so much as
luke is getting zapped
by lightning right this in this move
where the emperor's doing this and then
they post production put lightning bolts
on his hands so he was doing this in
front of the camera that wasn't a
practical effect they didn't know it was
oh my god i didn't actually actually
shoot lightning the more you know can we
get a star wipe now
and then and then darth vader picks up
the emperor spoilers and throws him down
spoilers movie came out in 1980
it's 30 something years ago uh spoiler
alert right so so that sounds like a
team up to me it's just like they're
both
electrocute that guy right so yes you're
not wrong there but at the same time
it's not like they're fighting together
they're not you know they're not like
back to back they're like shake and bake
let's go like that doesn't happen it's
more that you know darth vader redeems
himself
once does one
really good thing and then die one
parentheses one good thing ever
the good thing is killing a guy like
right
he basically kills like like the living
embodiment of evil in the entire
universe so that's pretty good if you're
gonna kill one more guy you pick a
that's a good one to redeem yourself and
you save your son in the process and
i've gotten away from the point i think
a better star wars good guy bad guy team
up is from the last jedi
when
kylo ren and rey team up to fight those
that's a good one guards
now
yeah and they you know
kylo ren kills snoke through subterfuge
in that scene and and in the moment and
even afterwards i was really frustrated
because i was like i really wanted some
backstory i wanted some more explanation
as to who this guy was who snoke was and
we never got it but
ultimately it fits in so well in my
opinion with the theme of the movie of
getting rid of the past forging a new
path forward
and yet at the same time
um well anyway the fight that follows is
really good it's visually exciting yeah
it's a great fight scene and whatever
your feelings about that movie might be
whether you like it whether you hate it
you can't deny it that's a great fight
oh i love that pic and i'm a last jedi
apologist partly because i do like that
it tries to subvert a lot of what
what star wars has set up in a really in
a way i find interesting and also
because i love ryan johnson and i think
he's like yeah i think i'm amazing it's
a great movie yeah i don't want to i
don't want to get too far into tv last
jedi but that is a great that's such a
visually striking fight scene i love
that fight scene huge highlight and
what's what's so good about it too is
that afterwards kylo ren is like joining
right
we're gonna do this thing and she's just
like no right haven't you been paying
attention right have you heard anything
i've said yeah and then he's an even
worse villain for the rest of the movie
yeah and so it's a great it's a really
great moment where the bad guy and the
good guy team up because their interests
align for just this brief window of time
and then
gone again i love that one so i really i
really like that scene and i love that
you picked sorry just quickly i love
that you picked that one instead of them
like ultimately teaming up in rise of
skywalker and then getting together
which i hate which i hated very much
thanks i hate it i don't want it um and
it's so much better it doesn't work at
all there's when they kissed i was like
what there was no payoff for that like
no set up nothing
yeah i hate
hate so i'm really glad you picked the
better team up of those two characters
yeah it's much better so much better
but wasn't the whole point of the the
new trilogy that if people do kissing
they disappear
like what
anybody that kisses in the star wars
movies winds up gone in the in the last
trilogy this is a fact disappears
later
on and leia
rose's screen time does kind of
disappear rose yeah that's right so
they're playing by the uh the
they're playing by scream rules
kissing people makes you go away a great
lesson for the children he's somebody
who is very into star wars in uh in
elementary junior high school i could
say this is probably the lesson that
people need to hear you'll get cooties
and you'll turn into a force ghost
yeah that's how it works everybody knows
exactly so so are you saying that
obi-wan kissed darth vader and that's
why he disappeared
i'm saying that you just quoted all of
my catholic sex ed classes that i ever
had and brian answered your question i'm
sure there's a fan fiction out there
that features that exact plot i'm sure
yeah as soon as i said i was like that
i'm sure that's out that's definitely
out there yeah
um i had a few other pictures that i
wanted to run through of really because
because this is one of those things
where when you see the topic like good
guy bad guy team ups you're like oh
there's got to be a million of them and
it's actually surprisingly difficult to
find ones
that work that are
memorable in good movies you know
um
one of them that made me really excited
was um in bill and ted's bogus journey
when they team up with death yeah that's
a really good one uh because he's
definitely a bad guy at the start he's
here to take them to the underworld and
they trick him and then he joins their
band right he's fantastic
jurassic park when the t-rex shows up to
save everybody mm-hmm is that great
choice that counts
the t-rex is not a good guy and then he
is a bank he is and then he is and then
he is she
right
that's right lady dinosaurs damn
um women dinosaurs can do anything right
i need to be more aggressive in my
dinosaur beliefs
mad max fury road yeah
right when nux
nux is one of the war boys and he's just
he's got max as his blood bag yeah he's
trying to die shiny and chrome he sprays
his face amazing and
eventually he joins up with the good
guys and helps them and he sacrifices
his life to help them uh on their way
that's nicholas that's right
and the last one i picked was the
rocketeer
oh and then
the gangsters find out they're working
for nazis
yeah
yeah there's this great line where he
says i may not make an honest buck but
i'm 100 american and i don't work for no
two-bit nuts
and then the the fbi shows up and they
start shooting the nazis and then the
gangsters and the fbi
are shooting the nazis together and
there's just this great moment where the
fbi guy and the gangster guy look at
each other and they're like
and then they keep shooting yes
let me ask you guys if this one
qualifies uh sirius black and in harry
potter
because for the whole third book in film
you're like serious black is the villain
he killed a bunch of people with one
curse blah blah not only is he harry's
godfather but
that has one of the best twists in that
entire series which is the peter
pettigrew has literally been there the
whole time masquerading as a pet rat
yeah i love that one that's that's a
that's
my understanding though yeah well no but
i mean he's clearly he's he's made out
to be the antagonist for for the film so
like for for the the large part of the
story of the book in the film
you think this is the bad guy this is
the villain you know if you
have read books before or no movies and
you're an adult you haven't you can
reasonably suss out that it's probably a
big misdirect but if you're a child for
whom these books and movies are made
you might actually think that the that
the bad guy is the person they're
telling you is the that when i first
read that book i was probably 12 or 13
and i remember being like whoa that i
did not see that yeah what it's alright
yeah no and then
harry literally teams up with sirius 2
before the book and film even
end to try to bring someone else to
justice i love it
love to see it that's a good one that's
a great one yeah
thanks for watching don't forget to hit
like and subscribe so you don't miss a
single episode thanks for watching we
love you goodbye
[Music]
you